[Music]
it is time
i mean i hope so i've had to wait
through two minutes of previously on and
logoing to get here
i actually might need to take a snack
break i think i have some turkish
delight around here somewhere
nope that's a rolo how could you free
him well you see there was this card in
a book that had a tiny note that made
two men fight to the death followed by a
guard murder and an outfit change none
of it would have been possible without
an impossibly deep understanding of the
layout of the prison mind you
were you followed no how can you be so
sure
because i know when i'm being followed
well that answers that then
no reason to double check anything do we
really have to litigate what may
or may not have happened there's nothing
in litigate you straight shot the man
one thing i'm really enjoying so far
about the mtu is that we're getting more
in-depth looks at characters that
weren't much more than side pieces in
the mcu
anthony mackie is kind of killing it in
this show and i'm now firmly in the sam
fan camp
sammys falconers the desire to become a
superhuman
cannot be separated from supremacist
ideals
anyone with that serum is inherently on
that path
that supremacist and the entire
neighborhood got together for a ceremony
it's like a week long maybe they're
doing the same thing for donya and by
sinful coincidence they are
one of the workers killed was the father
of two if they're all watching and
listening
to this on their phones how is there one
single audio stream shouldn't we be
hearing this dramatic news and surround
sound
wearing a car seat belt as a belt buckle
keep an eye on him keep an eye on him
sam and bucky are obviously very good at
what they do but letting zemo roam
around loose seems like an odd choice
zemo's clearly capable of causing a lot
of damage quickly he [ __ ]
shot the only lead they had you know for
a group of people who hate the grc they
seem to be surprisingly all right with
keeping up grc propaganda on the walls
well what's your name maybe i can make a
call i'd love to see that call get made
i'm sorry you're who oh you mean the guy
that helped break baron zemo out of jail
yeah yeah yeah we're totally gonna help
you just
stay right where you are turkish delight
was always my son's favorite
strangers with candy and she's no
different than him or anybody else we
fought
so then you're happy to help her too
right just like you're helping him
you know the guy brewing cherry blossom
tea and making an afternoon snack
it just feels like sam and bucky are
playing bad guy favorites and zemo's in
the lead because he can put them up in
some posh mosaic suite
you always used to tell me if you're
doing something and it makes you scared
it's probably because it's the right
thing this is terrible advice
i didn't think there could be another
captain america until i met you
worst pickup line ever or possibly best
but either way
back then there was just good and bad
but the world's more complicated now it
was never just good and bad
kids lack the ability to use foresight
and perceive the complexities of good
and bad which is why we have warning
labels on laundry detergent
but first we pay our respects to mama
dania but why i know she meant a lot to
you in the cause but carly's probably
the most wanted person in the world
right now
she really needs to get out of some of
her public appearances i can't figure
out why she's in this graveyard without
a cap
or sunglasses or anything she'll move in
fast
take her by surprise no i want to talk
to her alone i think john might have the
better idea here but i can't figure out
why just the two of them showed up
the grc wouldn't send some backup once
again carly and her group are the most
wanted people in the world
and they are all super soldiers might
need a little more firepower than
captain faux merica and lamar hoskins
can you show us the way what the hell
man i'm really starting to like this
john walker he's a little snarky and
rough around the edges but he seems to
have a good head on his shoulders
i'm really looking forward to his
character growth as he wrestles with his
anger and
comes out on top of it all we may even
get that sweet camera shot from below
where he stands heroically with
shield in the foreground it's gonna be
epic
also if zemo was going to bring sam and
bucky along with him this whole time
then why tell the girl
oh a little secret or they're very bad
not to be trusted wouldn't that lead to
the little girl being immediately
concerned and suspicious when he shows
up with four guys you got 10 minutes
and we're doing things my way setting an
arbitrary time limit just so someone can
ignore the time limit and ruin
everything when it was all going so well
cliche
how do none of the other flag smashers
notice the mysterious figure looming on
the second floor even if their backs
returned during the ceremony carly
glanced towards sam several times which
should tip them off
i know walker is trying to prove himself
as a worthy successor to captain america
and he's been pressing hard to get carly
captured but this transition from steve
rogers wannabe into a five o'clock
shadow
[ __ ] feels like we've missed a good
five or six scenes with walker and
hoskins that would explain his descent i
realize they've got to get us to the
ending of this episode but they've
skipped over what could have been some
really interesting scenes to get us
there
it doesn't matter that we see how zemo
got out of the handcuffs we just need to
see that he can
i lost her this place is amazed and yet
you found each other and zemo finds
carly without issue
neat so carly gets through walker
hoskins sam and bucky but gets derailed
by
zemo in a pistol yeah that adds up
also how does he keep getting guns
this episode is 17 michael myers head
tilting
stealing what did we miss
well i missed the part where the split
party found the dungeon map and managed
to reunite in a maze
did you find the vials they'd been
destroyed how did carly not already know
this
she just saw zemo stepping on them i
didn't give him the shield
well steve definitely didn't four
episodes in and we're still having the
shouldn't have given him the shield talk
do you want four sins show because this
is how you get four cents
he's actually proven himself useful
today by shooting
carly okay sure he gave candy to kids
like a creep and found out where the
funeral was going to be but i'm pretty
sure they could have attached a tracking
device on someone and figured it out
without the turkish delight what i'm
saying here is that this show really
goes the extra mile to justify trusting
zemo and they really shouldn't
the dora milaje are addicted to tiles
also why would the dora milaje chuck the
spirit captain america when zemo was
right there for the kabobbing was aio
seriously going to murder captain
america
because i think ayo was seriously going
to murder captain america
was she seriously going to murder
battlestar because i think she was
seriously going to murder
star and why is zebo still here
i can't believe he pulled in ochapo i
can't believe no one has followed him
are the dora melania afraid of sewers
everyone just casually looks at it yep
that's a holy wind down
probably leads somewhere else oh well if
i were to kill you
it'd be meaningless see i'm shaming
hello john walker
note to self the next time you ask
sharon to keep an eye out for walker
moving in on carly's base
ask her to give a warning before he's
directly on the base
thanks sharon sho doesn't want to take
the time to show us the scene of john
taking the serum but is more than happy
to show us zemo making tea and 38
discussions about how sam should have
taken the shield
[Applause]
why would anyone from carly's army react
this way to jon's serum or not bucky's
been a super soldier this whole time and
they haven't acted scared of him
this useless clock alright this part is
hard to watch
but i have to ask why everyone stops
fighting each other i understand walker
bucky and sam stopping to check in with
lamar but the flag smashers wanted to
kill walker and he's very distracted at
the moment why would they stop going
after their target
cool john's probably just going to ask
this guy for the quickest way for him to
find carly so he could calmly arrest her
for killing his friend
i i mean that hit to the face seemed a
little over the top but he's got him
subdued so he can once again
calmly obtain this infra holy [ __ ]
what is happening good luck getting
blood out of that shield john
i'm pretty sure you just can't run that
through a dishwasher
what the hell is going on here hulk
hogan has betrayed
wcw fire is good
fire is good yes fire fire is our friend
end of intro to funeral speech
good afternoon to everyone i'm kenny
powers
they started a war as soon as they
kicked us out of our new homes and onto
the street
people all around the world need me
millions of them i don't quite
see how you cherish the memory of the
dead by
killing another million and uh
personally i think you're a idiot i
thought we'd been
chosen you choo-choo choose me
where is she where is she i don't know